in dem video wird leider finde ich nicht
versucht mit den leuten zu kommunizieren
sondern es wird sehr klare meinung
vorgegeben und eigentlich genau das
gemacht für das wiso ja von vielen
politikern kritisiert wurde und was
sowieso meiner meinung nach in seinem
wie seinem video besser gemacht hat
nämlich auf fakten basiert mit quellen
belegt er seine meinung zu untermauern
und hier wird ja mit vielen
halbwahrheiten stimmung gemacht was sich
meiner meinung nach für eine partei die
teil der bundesregierung ist nicht
gehört inhaltlich finde ich das video
sehr gefährlich weil da eine fraktion im
bundestag und teil der der regierung
hingeht und sagt hier wir erzählen euch
was über tagespolitik und über unsere
arbeit im bundestag
was sie letztendlich aber machen ist
meinungsmache also sie stellen ihre
eigene position da als wären es fakten
wenn man den dialog startet mit die
grünen fliegen ganz viel um klettertour
merkel vor scheiße weil sie nicht ob
überhaupt ein dialog entsteht
und dann ist die gestaltung des videos
natürlich noch mal eine andere sache die
der anbiedernd wirkt sondern wir
brauchen irgendwie cooler sound effekte
und viele schnitte und das habe ich auf
youtube gesehen also machen wir das
jetzt auch so ohne verständnis zu haben
warum klingt heute so gemacht wenn wir
sie gemacht werden oder auch irgendwie
vielleicht zu versuchen ein eigenes ziel
mit rein zu bringen und zu versuchen
eben die eigenen stärken auszuspielen
die man vielleicht hat sondern erst
junge menschen gucken dass also müssen
wir jetzt auch auf teufel komm raus
versuchen jugend zu sein
sie sagen am anfang auch es geht um
tagespolitik ist unsere arbeit im
bundestag und das ist eigentlich das was
mir persönlich fehlt also ich glaube wo
man auch punkte mit hätte machen können
bei der cdu wo die man ansprechen möchte
indem man eben sagt okay das sind die
dinge die uns wichtig sind das nicht
dinge die wir machen
stattdessen ist das video 90% bashing
von ich nenne es mal politischen gegnern
oder andersdenkenden und ein ganz
kleiner teil ist dann so ein bisschen
lobhudelei okay wir haben ein team wie
60 70 prozent unserer versprechen im
koalitionsvertrag erfüllt aber
letztendlich wird gar nicht über das
über das tagespolitische oder das dass
die eigentlich arbeiten gesprochen was
eigentlich versprochen wurde und
vielleicht ändert sich das noch ich
glaube da könnte man tatsächlich punkten
indem man eben seine stärken ausspielten
dass ihnen zu sagen okay das sind dinge
die uns wichtig sind dass er dinge für
die bestehen dass die dinge die wir
gemacht haben und da diskutieren wer
jetzt ernsthaft darüber ohne die
kommentare zu deaktivieren und ohne zu
versuchen auf teufel komm raus cool zu
sein indem wir super viele soundeffekte
und schnitte damit einpacken